welcome to Hannity I'd like to say all
good news tonight is not a lot my heart
is troubled now we're going to go
through all the facts news information
that a lot of people in the media don't
want to give you protests continuing
across the country brand-new footage
from the murder of George Floyd
it shows how a crowd of on lick lookers
this is very hard video to look at
begging begging one of the other
officers at the scene to step in and
stop what was happening to george floyd
minute after minute after minute
it's excruciating we will play it with a
warning also meanwhile anarchy
lawlessness reigned supreme in seattle
police precinct there has been abandoned
by city officials another precinct that
minneapolis was burned to the ground
just a few weeks ago in riots that had
nothing to do with the honor of member
or memory of George Floyd eight hundred
cops now hurt some died and we now know
one is probably on life support for the
rest of his life and now by the way we
go to the city of Atlanta last Friday
night 27 year old man named Rashard
Brooks was shot and killed by an Atlanta
police officer the officer involved in
the shooting
Garrett Rolf his was fired immediately
by the way it's just breaking some 19
Atlanta officers have now resigned after
what has happened in this case we'll
have details coming up in a minute the
other officer on the scene was placed on
administrative duty there are now
growing calls for Ralph to be charged
with murder very different to what
happened with George Floyd and we will
go through this in great specificity in
detail also ya to become a more perfect
union reforms are needed desperately
needed way overdue
more training mandatory cameras and more
non-lethal options for the police must
be made available we can do that we'll
have more on that also coming up and
once again we need to put all emotion
aside let's start let's begin with facts
and as I've been saying for years I love
body cams and I love cameras inside of
patrol cars and they're extremely
helpful in understanding what really
happens that's why I didn't want to see
the show cops cancelled or live PD
canceled because we get to understand
the difficulty they a job and I believe
it keeps everybody honest it was about
10:30 p.m. Friday night two police
officers
to a call man was passed out behind the
wheel of a car at a Wendy's
drive-through literally blocking the
drive-through upon his arrival the
officers approached Rashard Brooks car
and attempted to wake him up
take a look
who
some of men
hey come in
hey hey man you parked the middle drive
to whine here you good you don't need a
little thing like that are you just
tired all right man just I'll move my
car just pull just pull somewhere in
second out all right all right you are
you just here for a visitor what's uh
I'm visiting revisited my mother's grave
site oh I'm sorry you know yeah I won't
she passport it's been probably about a
year and a half now first let me correct
the record that they would not 19 guys
that resigned in Atlanta that came
across a wire and we now have been able
to call and confirm it didn't happen
we'll have more on some police officers
and other cities though that are leaving
the force leaving the job some retiring
and someone just outright quitting as
you can see though from that video from
both Rashard Brooks and the police
courteous professional mr. Brooks
obviously very tired but he was also
respectful and as you saw the police
they offered condolences for mr. Brooks
mother who had recently passed away
courteous caring professional on every
level accorded in what I see few moments
later after suspecting that Brooks was
intoxicated the police performed an
alcohol sobriety test we have that video
to follow mr. Brooks
will you take it freely breath test for
a yes or no
I don't want of a few of any hey it's
yes or no it's completely up to you okay
just wait here while I go trying to make
sure man you stay to dry that's all I
know man I just you can't escape me
because you were sleeping in this nuts
you know why I was making sure you're
okay you know I know I know you did
still your job just take a deep breath
in put your mouth over the mouthpiece
bow as far as you can stop please stop
blah blah blah blah blah will stop very
good you had about one-and-a-half drinks
but you don't remember what kind of
makes me wonder if no fun all right
I really don't think you've had too much
to drink to be driving canceled I can
back away all right again up to this
moment when we get to the handcuffing
part both sides polite professional
cordial however Brooks failed the
sobriety test
there was no option for the police at
that point he was over the legal limit
police attempted to very cordially even
it you could say take him into custody
up until this moment from what we
thankfully see everybody from what I can
see it their best behavior courteous
polite etc by the book
and that's when at this second
everything goes south now this is a
viewer warning what you're about to see
from this point forward if you have kids
in the room it is extremely graphic take
a look
now seemingly as you could see on that
tape out of nowhere the moment the
police tried to cut mr. Brooks the video
shows
Rashard Brookes first resisting arrest
then attacking both police officers you
see the struggle both officers you can
see our hit and you hear the police on
tape clearly saying over and over stop
fighting stop fighting we will have to
tase you stop fighting stop grabbing the
Taser and then ultimately mr. Brooks
grabbed one of the tasers he stood up
cops are still on the ground the video
seems clear as mr. Brooks is running he
turns around and in fact as to what the
APD is now saying and seems to fire that
taser and the officer in foot pursuit
that's officer Rolf who was responding
he responded then by shooting mr. Brooks
twice in the back with a handgun
horrific scene and what is you watch
this what's so so sad to me about this
is up until that very second when they
attempted to handcuff him the exchange
was polite professional courtesy all
courtesies that on both sides all of
this did not have to happen our thoughts
and prayers with everybody involved in
this the Brooks family everybody
involved now you heard what sounded like
genuine niceness respect from mr. Brooks
Toad's the police and the police towards
him and everybody has to look at this
and wish this never happened this is not
like this is not at all like the 8
minutes and 46 seconds on tape of a cop
with the knee on the neck of George
Floyd but now the actions from these
officers on the scene will rightly be
scrutinized most likely I would guess by
a jury now before we get to the actual
law when I first saw the George Floyd
video all right it was Universal in this
country you know maybe a few keyboard
warriors you know anonymously tweeting
or writing something online in their
basement conservatives liberals agreed
that tape did not lie to us and I'm
gonna be consistent as I've always been
on this program and I consistent I mean
this we don't rush to judgment we
believe in due process we believe in the
presumption of innocence and for good
reason
we contact sources we talk to witnesses
we look at video we gather evidence we
look at the facts on the ground that's
why we were right for example in the
case of Michael Brown and officer Darren
Wilson so many others were wrong so many
others rushed to judgment and that's why
we predicted it would be difficult to
convict the officer similarly with the
murder
remember Baltimore Freddie gray in the
aftermath of that were also right about
Duke Lacrosse in that case the UVA case
the Cavanaugh act is a accusations I
learned my best lesson from Richard
Jewell when I was a local host in
Atlanta and so many more
according to Georgia State law this is
what the policy is and this will matter
in a court of law police may use deadly
force to apprehend a suspected felon
only when the officer reasonably
believes that the suspect possesses a
deadly weapon or an object device or
instrument which when used offensively
against any person is likely to result
in serious bodily injury we know after
the stealing of the Taser mr. Brooks
immediately became a suspected felon
that would be a felony but is a police
taser a deadly weapon or a device and by
the way could it be used to seriously
injure someone if the Taser and the
electrode wires have already been
discharged remember Brooks already shot
the Taser as he ran away from the
officers now Georgia law also permits
that leaf force from police this is the
law quote when the officer reasonably
believes that the suspect poses an
immediate threat of physical violence to
the officers or others or when there is
probable cause to believe that the
suspect has committed a crime involving
the infliction or threatened infliction
of Syria
physical harm but not only did mr.
Brooks initiate the conflict he also
stole the Taser he aimed it at a police
officer shot it well we can see on tape
and we all have all that video evidence
again that's why I like video cams on
cops and and in squad cars this would
have been at the end of the day what we
call a simple DUI nobody wants it but if
you drink your risk to others probably
in the first offensive it wasn't first
offense it's a misdemeanor charge you
get books you get a summons you get a
court date and usually you call somebody
to pick you up and you go home assuming
a first offense likely alcohol
counseling worst case license suspension
and so that which means it's all sad
tragic unnecessary